a very pregnant ciara involved in a  scary car crash friday in LA you know I  just need you got to keep praying for  this is good again luckily et can  confirm Sierra and the baby are doing  well following the incident everything's  fine really good after the crash a  spokesperson for the singer explained in  a statement quote the driver was  illegally in the bus lane and hit the  right side of her car the LA fire  department tells us the traffic accident  was reported around noon no patients  were transported from the scene  authorities at the west LA traffic  division add the collision only caused  property damage Sierra is currently in  her third trimester and expecting her  and husband Russell Wilson's first child  together I'm enjoying life right now and  and life is pretty sweet  [Music]